you probably know this I've read a whole
lot about your five season plan but I
know that plans do evolve as you make a
show and you hear the response to the
season that you just shot so what of
that plan would you say change the most
given your experience shooting season
one and then also how people reacted to
the material in season one well I mean
we might have different answers to this
yeah well I mean like yeah because like
well
I don't know if this is like lame but
it's like there's a part of me that
doesn't want to answer because it's like
I hate
like the idea of somebody in like kind
of the audience like a feeling like you
know the thing that they got wasn't
somehow like whole because it's like in
a kind of my mind you know there are
lots of changes uh big and small that
happen as part of this process and it's
one of the best parts of the process but
I guess like I tend to think of it as
like well that's the way it was always
supposed to be uh uh um it's not that we
couldn't get the thing or like uh this
didn't work out uh um it's just that's
not what it was supposed to be it was
supposed to be this so yeah I'm with you
Bart like some years ago there was a I
think there was an experiment in
Hollywood where people could choose
their own adventure it was a play on you
know play running called sure Madness
where you got to choose the ending and
they sort of found out that it really
didn't work because people wanted to be
grabbed by the lapels and taken through
a story that they felt was really
cohesive and so I'll answer for myself I
mean the audience reaction is is we're
so grateful for it and it's so
meaningful to us but we we can't let it
affect too much our process in the
writer's room we must trust our own
impulses and as we start hurting the
cats metaphorically speaking of our
writers and like brainstorming and blue
skying things start to emerge that just
instinctively feel right to us and so
I'm not saying we ignore our audience
feedback of course it's really
interesting and meaningful to us but at
the same time we've got to keep the
Integrity of the story that we're
telling and try and not allow that to
affect us too much because then it
becomes sort of like a slightly impure
process with that in mind is there
anything forget the audience reaction is
there anything that instinctively
emerged via the making of season one
where you discovered that there was more
to something than you ever realized was
there originally and you got to expand
upon that in season two I think that
there were a few things that we
always hoped we could do but season one
gave us the confidence to dig deeper
into you I think a great example is the
family Dynamic amongst the sedekis
because Warren Cole and Sarah Desjardins
are both incredible and had we not
gotten so incredibly lucky with their
casting I don't know that we would have
been able to explore as deeply but
because they were both so great in
season one we were like well let's let's
go for it like let's really expand on
this and I think that you know we always
knew that that Shauna's relationship to
her daughter and her relationship to
Motherhood was going to be a big deal
but knowing that we have such an
incredible Game actor and Sarah allowed
us to just give her more to do which was
yeah I would add that when Warren came
on and he did such a great job
portraying Jeff you know Jeff could have
just been the schlubby accessory to
Shauna's uh storyline and like the the
husband that was used at the butt of the
job but in fact what wound up happening
because of their chemistry and we hope
because of the writing you know we start
to roof for them and they're a very
grounded meaningful couple to our
audience now and that is such a pleasure
so we get to explore you know where they
can go from here and Warren took a a
real Leap of Faith with us yeah because
you know we knew that early on we we
wanted to pull a little bit of a bait
and switch with Jeff you know we
introduced him in the pilot as a
teenager and he is kind of an idiot and
you know then when we first introduce
him it's clear that this is a marriage
that kind of came from more of a place
of guilt and sort of self-justification
for what Shawna had done then you know
true love but we we kept trying to
essentially assure Warren we were like
because you know again I think that that
he was maybe rightfully concerned for a
little bit that he was just kind of the
doofy husband and we were like you got
it you gotta go with us Warren like we
will earn this back and we talked about
it a lot in the room and uh we were just
like we're gonna we're gonna win people
over to Jeff like that is our goal and
if we don't succeed then then we have
not done our jobs correctly we have
confirmed great success in that respect
yeah no well and like uh like uh uh
that's one of the things that was very
funny was like like it kind of happened
in the room where it's just like like
people's like I really like Jeff yeah
it's like sort of a surprise for all of
us right yeah you know who else everyone
really likes van and I might have seen
some quotes floating around that
originally you were planning to kill off
Vans for season one yes many questions
about that one when and how was that
character originally going to die and
now moving forward what what like
Corners are you able to explore
specifically because that character is
back in the in the equation here I think
what's interesting is that it's not that
she was ever definitely meant to die
it's just that the opportunity for her
death kept coming up and then we kept
writing away from it and I think part of
that is is very much a credit to live
because they are phenomenal and even you
know in the pilot itself van was not
given a particularly big part and Liv
found some great moments you know some
of them were scripted but some of them
were Improv I think one of my favorite
things that van does in the pilot and
this was all live was as Jackie saying
you know yellow jackets with Bean is
about to get them a talking to Liv
decided to just go back and get a little
bit more beer and we were like that is
such an incredible van character moment
and you know this the more fun these
characters are the harder it is to part
with them I mean the one who was
legitimately going to die in the pilot
from our conception and our pitch was
Laura Lee and Jane brought so much
Humanity to that part that you know
we're like okay well I think we still
have we have to kill somebody at some
point right it was it was really hard
like in a lot of ways uh Jane made it a
self-fulfilling prophecy because she is
so good you know like we we didn't kill
her at that point when what Ashley just
referred to but because she was so good
in the course of the Season we thought
that that would be a very meaningful
character death and we decided to go for
it in episode eight lesson and so R.I.P
Rachel Rachel became the early
smart ways to pick pivot and recognize
then so I was really curious about your
experience doing this because it was
something that really impressed me about
the beginning of season two how do you
figure out how to incorporate
yellow jackets that were technically
that that technically weren't there all
along but now you're presenting them as
characters that like we need to believe
had been there the entire time in season
one and and know that the audience feels
that naturally I guess because I I
didn't think that was gonna work and I
was surprised how quickly I fell into
step with that group yeah yeah I think
that part of it is like I mean like I
think that
you know a television is not a kind of a
novel or kind of a feature like you
don't have the entire plan and like for
better and for worse and I and I guess I
don't know I mean I'm sure that like
this is uh an extreme uh kind of a
statement that I will like back away
from 10 minutes after this kind of
interview is over but like leaning into
the realities of kind of the medium that
you're kind of working in like uh
whether it's like like a limit or uh uh
uh an expansiveness of it I think is
almost always the right answer like and
so just to acknowledge that it's like
okay we can't you know cast all of these
people in two timelines you know uh
right from day one that's just not
financially viable but then just sort of
like you know like doing it um in a way
that's not trying to pull a fast one
that is trying to be as like
non-um like bumpy as possible but also
says no no like you uh I'll I'll like uh
oh we kind of know we're not getting one
by you
um just seems to be like the best way to
personally don't regret saying that I
feel like it's well worth talking about
balancing the business with the art but
it's such a really important part of
success here absolutely production
reality and I think that you know some
some of our audience is Savage of that
and some are less so because how could
they be they're not in the business but
the the fact is that one in season one
we were dealing with kovid which meant
we had to have smaller sets and you know
we did make it difficult for ourselves
you know it's because of the isolation
of the cabin you know we knew that there
were going to be other characters but
you can't you know you can't cast
somebody phenomenal and then give them
one line or two every once in a while so
we we knew that we were gonna have to
play it this way and
um hopefully you know people go with it
and and we got very lucky also in that
Maya Lo who plays Jen
um was around first season and and
really impressed us I mean that was
actually one of our first instincts in
season two was as opposed to recasting
all those parts we thought you know Maya
was great like let's bring Maya in and
see what she can do and it turns out she
can do a lot so that worked out really
well
um but yeah you know it really is just a
casting reality you know if if you know
that you're not going to be able to
truly develop those characters until
later you really can't cast it until you
can yeah and you really want to get the
audience leaning in on the main Core
Group first right before you do sort of
like Rosencrantz and Guildenstern and
their point of view so once we decided
that like okay now they're invested in
our main characters then you could
really ask the question of like well
what are the other girls thinking about
what's happening in our storyline and so
you know that's the crystal storyline
that we now sort of excavate this season
and um I think like you let the story
lead you into sort of like what you need
hmm and the fact is is that at that age
you know there are clicks and there are
sort of hierarchies and you know there
are plenty of people that I went to high
school with that I barely interacted
with in vice versa you know so it
actually makes a certain amount of sense
obviously because of the the size of the
cabin and where we are it makes it a
little bit trickier and yeah I think
that what was really fun was starting to
see some personalities outside of our
Core group and you know there are a
couple of moments where
um Jen Jenna who plays Melissa just like
nailed a couple of whites it's like
she's really funny this is great and
then you know we all kind of fell in
love in the writer's room with Crystal
pretty early on so she's so good